so Revelations from Prince Harry more
strikes on the cards and a big speech by
its kirstama yesterday lots to talk to
Labor's Shadow Chiefs actually the
treasury Pat McFadden this morning very
good morning nice to see you here thanks
for joining us first of all I do want to
ask you very briefly about Prince Harry
because so many people are talking about
this and I spoke to Lord Kim Derek just
a few minutes ago a former National
Security advisor of course about his
Revelations about his time in
Afghanistan and he said to me that if
he'd have been advising him he would
advise against the level of detail do
you have any concerns about some of the
revelations that have come out in this
book
I think people will make all sorts of
comments on this but you know in terms
of advice my advice to politicians like
me and others is you know well we're
seeing all this play out it's probably
not very wise for us to say very much
about it you know I hope that in time
this manages to get patched up within
the the royal family but I think it's
probably the best course of action for
MPS not to say too much about it right
now okay fair enough let's talk about
strikes then shall we and this morning
um The Times newspaper is reporting that
the leader of the nursing unit the RCN
Pat Cullen is saying that she's willing
to meet the government halfway over pay
and has suggested that she would
consider an offer of around 10 a long
way shorter course of the 19 that the
union is asking for would labor back at
10 pay offer to the nurses well what she
said shows it's a negotiation because
the rtn started off asking for a lot
more than that and negotiation is how
this has to end uh and what we've got at
the moment from the government instead
of that is this threat of new
legislation rather than negotiation I
can talk about the legislation in a
moment we'll come to that but the
problem about reaching for that right
now is that's a threat to firing nurses
not to hire nurses so I you know the the
percentage that this is ended on or
settled on will have to be resolved
around the negotiating table and I hope
that ministers will meet Pat Cullen uh
we'll talk about that but the precise
End Settlement has to be negotiated but
does 10 sound reasonable to you as a
broad principle would do you want to see
nurses enjoying a pay rise that's in
line with inflation when we were in
government we managed to raise nurses
pay we managed to reduce NHS waiting
lists and times and we left office with
the highest levels of public
satisfaction in the service ever
recorded and we never had a national
strike like no that's the approach that
we take but I'm not going to come out
today when I'm not a party to the
negotiations and say it should be this
percent or that percent I want nurses to
be fairly rewarded but the precise
figure has to be negotiated between
their Union and the NHS okay but I'm not
asking for precise figures but yeah
principles you're asking me to connect
to a percentage that's not wise for me
to do that's to be negotiated but this
isn't just a politician ducking the
issue this is how it should be
approached that should be negotiated
between the union and the employers
around the table okay so it's not doc
initially can I ask you if you think
that they should get more than the three
percent that's I mean that's quite a
broad range that could go to more than
three percent that's on the table now
well these things are usually settled in
this way the union will have asked for a
particular uh percentage or a particular
pay level at the beginning the employers
may have awarded something and usually
this is settled with a compromise where
maybe not everybody gets what they want
or what they said at the beginning of
the negotiation I think that's the
spirit in which it should be approached
but the precise figure it's settled on
has to be resolved on the table okay we
hovered to kiss armor yesterday laying
out he talked about Big Ideas he talked
about change and
people may take that on board but they
ultimately want to have
a clear answer on the key issues that
the country is facing now one of those
key issues is the strikes and they feel
they're not getting answers from labor
on this you don't want to put even a
broad Principle as far as nurses pay is
concerned well I think we have been
clear on the strikes we've said we don't
want these to happen we want the
government to roll its sleeves up and
get negotiating and to get the nurses
back to work get the trains running
again and in the longer term to improve
Public Services now if you take the NHS
for example we've produced a very clear
plan fully costed to train more doctors
and more nurses and answer the long-term
staffing issues that the NHS is facing
paid for by the abolition of the non-dom
tax break and that's the spirit in which
we'll approach these things we'll come
out with a policy we'll see how it's
going to be paid for and that's the
approach that we'll take at the next
election right now with this threat of
government legislation what we've got is
ministers making a pause rather than
striking a deal and it's striking a deal
that is what has to happen here well on
that anti-strike legislation it's kiss
number yesterday said that he would
repeal any new restrictions but
explain to people why it's such a bad
idea to have a minimum safety standard
as the government is is now calling it
when it comes to crucial Industries like
fire Rail and ambulance services why is
that such a bad idea
even the
Secretary of State for transport has
said that it would have no impact on the
current strikes and in the longer term
the department for transport's own
assessment of this legislation thought
it could lead to more disputes in the
future rather than fewer so what I think
what I see when I see the government
doing this is really an admission of
failure they are admitting that they've
failed to successfully resolve these
disputes so they are reaching for
legislation which they hope will form
some sort of dividing line it is
striking a pose rather than striking a
deal and striking a deal is what has to
happen to get these Public Services back
to work and beyond that
even when we don't have straight days
and we've got a lot of strike days right
now but even when we don't if you look
at Public Services right now can we see
it as a single public service that's
working better now than 13 years ago
when the conservatives came to power
they've gone backwards so the challenge
for ministers isn't just resolving the
current disputes it's what are they
going to do about public services in the
future
but there are already laws out there
that ban the police from striking and
they're already rules around nurses
going on strike they have to make sure
that they only walk out if it doesn't
risk the well-being of patients so do
you agree with those rules and is this
not just that along with there are lots
there are laws around uh striking
members have to vote for this in a
ballot notice periods have to be given
and so on these are not the kind of
Wildcat strikes that we saw in the 1970s
I wish they weren't happening I want to
see the waiting list coming down I want
to see the trains running and so on but
these these strikes have been voted for
by the members so I think the response
from ministers
shouldn't be a legislative one it should
be our negotiating one and we're not
seeing that at the moment and that's why
these are rumbling on now into six
months or more okay well Pat McFadden we
appreciate your time this morning thanks
so much for coming in thank you